because he wasn't there that's nobody
that's that's cameraman and a three were
you on the floor yeah you and the whole
here though no you weren't here though
or to the side of it
hey I'm Matthew McConaughey this is Guy
Ritchie and this is and you're going
we're gonna break down a scene from the
gentleman for ya here we go hey you
again out of the game did you stay -
yeah
Lizzie Monday ones your day ones my day
- and I would like you to consider an
offer well Connie stop you right there
so you don't waste any more your
precious breath young man this is not a
discussion for the two of us unlike the
salt-and-pepper it's not on the table
where'd you come up with something like
the salt pepper to run on the table well
cuz the sole pepper was over the table
you stop you right there so you don't
waste any more your precious breath
young man this is not a discussion for
the two of us unlike the salt and pepper
it's not on the table this is a big
number
it's cropping number it's not be enough
- okay thank you first up this is what
do you call this Brenda Kiely when how
long you extend the number punching on a
calculator I'm not sure I mean it was
always trying trying to get this balance
before you saw if you pulled the rug out
from underneath the stakes I see you've
got sort of dance just on the edge of
the stakes cuz you get if you get if you
hang on too long with the numbers off
what's going on here and then it's the
it shifts but you've got to add if I
went out three times yeah I know yeah it
was a big number
it's a massive number of military get it
wrong I am NOT for sale and even if I
was your several zero short and he may
be but by MN sausage for that but to me
it just looks really breakfast you're
how touch
you're forgetting the laws of the jungle
looking down on me
and when the Silverbacks got more silver
than back the best move on before he has
moved on this sort of scene was was very
sort of dialogue heavy between me and
Matthew it often sort of changed and
weaved but where do you see changes but
as we're saying first of all let's talk
about that the structure of the scene is
is that you're a young turk and he's an
old dog and he has to you're too cocky
and he has to without to avert ly put
you in your place
he has to find an elegant way of putting
you down so things just like the salt
and pepper are just they're just little
diminishment so just put you back in
your place so the whole scene is about
him trying to diminish an inflated sense
of you and that's why it's a he
patronizes you all the way through the
scene and you dance with him quite
elegantly so you can hold your own but
he can smell trouble
oh yeah coming over the horizon
it's not dignified it's beneath you
Michael trying to do you a favor this is
a big number this right there's where he
over put you or play your hand mm-hmm
rather rather clumsily I think it's
about to come yeah so in all your
naivety he comes stumbling in but this
is this whole yeah it's really about
mistake he Karnas for weakness right and
I think you and I talked about this at
the beginning in the world of
criminality like there's a point where
the young succeed the old or at least
they want to but if they if they get the
timing wrong it's a disaster in the last
room all right but the other thing is as
you grow older you do acquiesce to more
the practical aspects of life private
schools stratification fire wine black
eggs I saw hands and that's a very
seductive narrative that one finds
oneself in now the question is is your
is your genteel refinery gonna is that
going to be seen as a weakness and is
your kindness being taken for weakness
I mean why like was that there's no way
you take a meeting with him in the first
place but the only reason you'll take a
meeting with him is because you tickled
your wife in the right way so to speak
and this
this is a big gun for Mickey for me was
you know extremely calm both the time
but in a split-second goes from zero to
a thousand and that dynamic was who he
was for me does it you know once Mickey
knows he's pulling the gun it's from
zero to a thousand like that and
hopefully there would be a dynamic and
that that you would be oh I didn't know
he had that side I didn't expect that
and then back down to calm but not be
ramping up into it full calm then animal
it was quite an interesting character
that yeah character that can refine
himself into a into gentrification and
middle-class but still is a hard hard
boiled on the street and if you can hold
both those positions in one personality
is an interesting personality
[Music]
not to join
[Music]
parts of it
looking for your balls on the wall well
that's that little run on that make it
goes on there something that we we
didn't realize yeah made up on the day
look in fear looking for your balls or a
hole in the wall rolling along deluded
duck eating things that sounded lyrical
and music yeah well Amy okay
it wasn't a car remember how that was
scripted actually when you where you
really get shot at what point of the in
shock so yeah you start having a bit of
fun there do me yeah yeah a little
journey we had to fill that journey and
that little tirade which are imposed
rather poetic and wonderfully delivered
but yeah for the table to well of course
all things are fantasy too which is
rather fun yeah do you think you're
going because you're not going out the
way you came in you deluded about the
laws of the jungle
beneath me there's only one room this
jungle when the Lions hungry
did I come did I come up with that one
lion hungry eat I think in the screw
there was a lot of lion many laws about
the Lion of the territory yeah yeah and
we're missing our course because we're
missing the next part the same knife
it's the same thing comes all it
switches back yeah and you and then you
go into a war they'll search peel back
the the dragon yes yes yes yes oh the
lesson lesson listen listen listen
listen a parable yes there was at one
point it wasn't going to be about laws
of the jungle the title of the film was
laws of the jungle or sometime it was
but there's two films coming out he
quite close proximity they're also a
jungle in the title so I couldn't use
jungle in the tile so we extracted
ourselves from the jungle there and
there's not quite so many lion metaphors
as the laws at the beginning yet you and
I talked quite a lot about in various
stages about the significance of a lion
it was a bulldog at one point it was a
bulldog in a drain
there's only one this shot of a Mickey
above tried day one didn't we cuz he
wasn't there that's nobody that's that's
cameraman and a three were you on the
floor yeah you and the whole here though
no you weren't here though or along to
the side of it okay Wow okay okay okay
when I watch these things I have no idea
that I didn't need to do with
construction of them and it's a it's the
funny thing about film is how you can
take yourself out of the role of a
director and contributor right and you
just you'll project you're looking at a
fantasy and as that sort of buildup I
thought forgotten where it ends it's
funny how many how often you can watch a
film that you made and wrote then you
don't sure how it ends and what the next
scene is and one of the things about
this and as we shot it comes the second
day it did make me up the aggression but
did turn up the aggression because truth
is or more of that yeah and I like that
sort of stuff
thanks for watching
get your tickets on Fandango the movie
comes out in the United States January
the 24th